Toys "R" Us: It's become a sad subject.
I never wanted to see the day where Toys "R" Us is a sad subject.
I'm sure you've heard by now...
...and if you haven't, I'm sorry I'm the one who had to break it to you,...
...but Toys "R" Us is done,...
...in the US, anyway.
In Canada, a company called Fairfax bought them,...
...so there's still going to be 80 of them spread across the country,...
...but with the exception of that, it's over!
As of this moment, they're in the process of closing 735 US locations...
...and they're nearing the end of the process.
Here's what happens when I call them.
Here.
Thank you for calling Toys "R" Us.
We would like to thank you for shopping with us for over 70 years...
...and we appreciate your kind expressions as we close our doors.
As of March 23rd, Toys "R" Us will start liquidation.
Here are a few frequently asked questions for your reference.
And then they just talk about how they're not accepting gift cards...
...and things like that.